marcará buenos días a todos ustedes no
como ustedes decían en el informe ningún
grupo se ha atribuido pero realmente la
atención que se ha vivido especialmente
en los alrededores de la zona de bagdad
en la zona verde de bagdad los últimos
días ha sido bastante grande estas
milicias llamadas hackers xavi
especialmente grupos más cercanos e irán
especialmente una conocida como jaja
site al haq hallaba ha llevado a todos
sus seguidores porque protestan por el
resultado de estas elecciones hace un
mes esto llevó a enfrentamientos entre
las fuerzas de seguridad iraquíes y
estas milicias y terminó con un muerto
lo que causó aún mayor rabia y la
reacción especialmente del líder de
estas milicias qais al jazali que
especialmente en el día de ayer había
dicho que la sangre de estos mártires
iba a tener venganza hoy él mismo ha
reaccionado y ha dicho que este ataque
tenía que ser investigado por un comité
y que si era genuino entonces él lo
condenaría y por qué dicen que si es
genuino porque muchas de estas milicias
especialmente cercanas a irán esta
mañana a se han reído de este ataque han
dicho que esto es una pantomima del
primer ministro para llamar la atención
y quererse ver como un mártir así que la
tensión entre el primer ministro y esos
grupos milicianos más que todos cercanos
a irán es cada vez mayor y usted
mencionó las elecciones de octubre como
estos comicios despertaron este nivel de
tensiones como se llegaron hasta esta
así que sigue ahora para el país
bueno lo que pasa es que especialmente
dos grandes agrupaciones cercanas a
estas milicias una la coalición al fateh
de que había tenido la segunda votación
en las elecciones pasadas tuvo pésimas
resultados en estas elecciones y ellos
han movilizado a su gente llamando al
fraude dicen los analistas quienes
conocen el sin nuevo sistema electoral y
de aquí es que si bien tuvieron votos
tuvieron muchísimos candidatos lo que
llevó a que su número de representación
en el parlamento fuera menor ellos han
llegado a criticar al primer ministro
como responsable de este cambio en la
ley electoral diciendo
y va en contra de ellos así que la pelea
es cada vez mayor estamos en un proceso
de formación de gobierno es casi seguro
que al alcance de mí no sea el próximo
primer ministro pero la atención como
vemos con este a quién irak lo han
llamado como un golpe de estado hacia
esta intención de querer atentar
directamente frente a la casa y frente
al primer ministro así que vamos a ver
muchísima más tensión en las próximas
semanas cuando ya empiecen las
negociaciones en busca de encontrar
quién es ese primer ministro de estas
milicias especialmente la agrupación al
fateh como hablaba se niegan a reconocer
los resultados de estas elecciones sin
embargo quien es su gran patrona aliado
que es irán ha llamado a condenar este
atentado y ha estado apoyando al primer
ministro así que vamos a ver cuáles sean
los desarrollos en los próximos días que
serán cruciales para la estabilidad de
irak sin ninguna duda